تماما يجب ان يكون وقفنا واضحا جدا في هذا
الخصوص وعلى ايران ان تعترف بعد ان
اوكرانيا في البدايه يجب ان تعترف بين
المسارات الايرانيه تستخدمها روسيا في
اوكرانيا وهذه المسيارات تستخدم
لارتكاب جرائم حرب فاعتقد بان اتحاد حقا
تماما في فرض العقوبات وفي الاسبوع المقبل
وزراء الخارجيه الاتحاد الاتحاد
ولكن
لا يمكن فقط
ايراني الدمويه النظام الايراني
العقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب بتحقيقات
شفافا وكنا داعمين لمفوضيه تحقيقات في
مجلس في حقوق الانسان في الامم المتحده
كان عام الذين تغييره فيما خصوص سياستنا
تجاه ايران وانا اسود عليك لان النمسا
كانت تجمعها علاقات قويه مقربه وطوله
الامد ماير علم نغلقه الصعبه
عم تساوي
ناخذ من عطفا حادا في سياساتنا تجاه ايران
بسبب الاعمال التي تقوم بها طهرا ردود
الفعل الاوروبيه والدوليه الحقيقه فيما
يتعلق بايران بعيدا عن المسيرات التي
تستخدم في الحرب في اوكرانيا انما فيما
ذكرته من الوضع الداخلي الايراني هذه
الانتفاضات والاحتجاجات وهذا القمع من قبل
النظام الايراني كيف تنظر اليها هل هي
مساويه للحدث هل هي بحجم هذه الازمه داخل
ايران
يجب ان نميز الوضع في اوكرانيا يشمل
الدوله تغزوا دوله مجاوره
النبي صدام حسين وغزوه للكويت ما نشهده في
ايران الان هو انتفاضه داخليه
يرغبون بالتعبير
السياسات
التي اطلقتها روسيه ضد الدوله